- Can you explain how
a sewing machine works?
I mean, think about it.
We've all seen them.
There's that little
needle that's moving up
and down really fast, leaving a trail
of stitches behind them.
But if you think about it for a second,
how are they doing it?
Because the needle is
never actually going fully
through the fabric.
If you're hand sewing, you have
to pass the needle up and down.
You have to let go of the needle
and grab onto it on the other side.
So in order to invent the
sewing machine, we first had
to invent a whole new way of sewing.
It's one of these things that
almost no one thinks about,
but is so important.
Every piece of clothing you've ever put
on virtually was made by a sewing machine.
So in this video, I'm going to explain
how sewing machines work.
And I promise when you
find out, you will find it
so incredibly satisfying.
And what you'll realize is
that these machines are performing
tiny mechanical miracles every second.
A part of this video was brought to you
by KiwiCo, more about them
at the end of the show.
- The foot pedal is right
in front of your right foot.
You can gently rest it. It
doesn't need a lot of pressure.
So easy does it, and you
should be able to start going.
- All right. Ah, all right.
(sewing machine rumbling)
This is amazing.
- [Noah] I find it meditative.
- If I were going to sew two pieces
of fabric together, this
is how I would do it.
Weaving the needle back
and forth through both pieces of fabric.
This is known as a running stitch,
and there are more sophisticated
stitches you could do.
But if you're trying to mechanize
any hand stitch, you run
into a major problem, which is
that any time you pass the needle
through the fabric, you have
to release it on one side
and pick it up again on the other side.
This is almost impossible
for a machine to do,
at least a machine from 200 years ago.
So in order to invent the
sewing machine, we first needed
to come up with a totally
new way of sewing.
And this came in three breakthroughs.
(dramatic music)
Human have been sewing clothes
for tens of thousands of years.
In 2016, researchers found a
needle in a cave in Siberia
that dates back to about 50,000 years ago.
The crazy thing is
that homo sapiens didn't
live in that cave.
It was inhabited by the
Denisovans, a now extinct species
of early humans.
So sewing isn't just a homo sapien thing,
it is a human thing.
The needle is made of bone.
But in other regards, it
looks like any modern needle,
a sharp end pierced through fabric
and an eye on the other
end for the thread.
Needles have remained basically unchanged
for tens of thousands of years.
Artifacts from caves in
France, ancient Egypt, Greece,
India, China, and Japan,
all look about the same.
That is until 1755.
Charles Frederick Wiesenthal was a
German inventor living in England.
We're not exactly sure what motivated him,
some believe he was trying
to invent a sewing machine,
but maybe he was just tired
of flipping the needle
over twice every stitch.
But what he created was
a needle that was sharp
on both sides, so you
could pass the needle back
and forth through the fabric
without flipping it over.
He patented his invention, a
needle for ornamenting fabrics,
which may have sped up sewing a little.
But the two-sided needle
delivered an unexpected benefit
used by all sewing
machines up until this day.
It moved the eye of the
needle next to the sharp tip.
But how does that help?
When I put the needle
into the fabric, the thread
does go below the fabric,
but when I pull it out, the
thread also gets pulled out.
So it seems like we've achieved nothing.
We need to find a way to tangle the thread
when it's at the bottom of the stitch
to stop it from pulling out.
And luckily, there are
two ways of doing this.
(dramatic music)
If you can keep a loop of
thread underneath the fabric,
as I pull the needle out, well
then, I can move the fabric
over and pass that needle
through the loop, forming a little link.
And if I do that again, I can form a chain
of these stitches.
That is why this is
known as a chain stitch.
The chain stitch was one
of the first stitches
successfully performed
by sewing machines.
It's really hard to say
who invented the first sewing machine.
There were just so many people working
on the problem at the same time
and there are many competing claims.
In 1790, Thomas Saint drew
detailed patent drawings
for a sewing machine design,
but there is no evidence
that he ever built a prototype.
In 1814, Joseph Madersperger
was granted a patent in Vienna.
It took him a decade to build the machine,
but he never commercialized it.
He spent the rest of his life
trying to perfect the design.
In 1830, Frenchman Barthélemy Thimonnier
built his own version.
It created a chain stitch
with a barb needle.
He was granted a patent
and set up a garment factory
with 80 of his machines.
There, they began manufacturing uniforms
for the French army but this
invention caused an uproar.
A mob of 200 angry tailors
ransacked his factory
and destroyed all of his machines.
It took a few more decades
before sewing machines
were reliable enough
to be commercially viable.
The two most reliable ways
to build a chain stitch
machine were invented
at nearly the same time
in 1857, when James Gibbs
and Charles Raymond received
their respective patents.
It was easy enough for me
to grab the loop of thread
in the model, but it's much more difficult
to design a machine to do
this reliably and repeatedly.
Charles Raymond's design used a hook.
The needle punctures the fabric
and carries the thread down with it.
Then as the needle moves up,
the thread between the eye
and the fabric shortens
and buckles forming a
little bulge of thread.
At exactly this instant, the
sharp hook catches the bulge,
stretching it into a loop.
And as the needle comes back
down, the hook moves backwards
and the needle passes through the loop.
The needle comes all the way down
and then as it moves back up,
the thread between the eye
and the fabric buckles again,
the hook catches this
bulge pulling the thread
into a loop for the needle
to pass through once more.
Gibbs had a similar design,
but the hook was rotating.
So as the needle lowers
the hook grabs the thread,
the rotating hook spins around,
the first loop is released,
and then the hook grabs the second loop.
It took Gibbs thirty-seven
prototypes, all carved outta wood
to get this incredible
looper shape just right
and then that same shape was used
on over 80 models of sewing
machines for 80 years.
The looper was held by pieces
of metal tightly enough
that it didn't fall out,
but with enough of a gap
for the thread to pass
through all the way around.
We are showing a simplified
model here for clarity.
But there's a flaw with this simple way
of making a chain stitch.
If the thread comes
loose, you can easily pull
out all the stitching.
It's remarkable how quickly
and easily the thread gets pulled out
because there's barely any
friction with the fabric.
The only friction holding each
stitch in place is the loop
from the previous stitch.
So once one goes, they
just all go in a chain.
So people developed more
complex chain stitches
that use more thread and are more robust.
You'll likely find chain
stitches holding the hem
of your jeans together.
You can also embroider beautiful patterns
with the chain stitch.
- Anything that kind of
had decorative stitches is
what it was originally used
for, but then it became used
for all kind of lettering and flowers.
- You're sort of doing
gymnastics figuring out,
if I feel it this direction,
where is my next path gonna be?
You're trying to kind of
think ahead of yourself.
And I think as you become more
skilled with the chains too,
that's where your work begins
to look a lot more refined.
(sewing machine rumbling)
- Besides the chain stitch,
there is a completely different
way to secure the thread.
And honestly, it's kind of genius.
All it requires is two
separate spools of thread.
Now this spool of thread
is called the bobbin.
So here's how it works.
The needle goes through two pieces
of fabric all the way down,
and then you pass the second
spool of thread completely
through a loop in the top spool,
and then bring the needle
back up, pull in the excess
and what we have done is interlocked
these two pieces of thread.
That's why this is known as a lock stitch.
In 1846, Elias Howe patented it
and to promote his new creation,
he staged a live sewing demonstration, him
and his sewing machine
versus five seamstresses.
Howe's machine worked,
but it wasn't elegant.
The machine used a curved
needle, the fabric hung
down vertically, and it
could only make stitches
in a straight line.
Five years later, Allen
B. Wilson dramatically
improved the lock stitch sewing machine
receiving two patents, one
in 1850 and one in 1851.
The first patent was
for the vibrating shuttle
lock stitch machine.
Although it's called a vibrating shuttle,
it actually oscillates back and forth
and inside it is a small bobbin of thread.
As it moves forward, it
catches the top thread
from the needle forming a
loop and as the shuttle passes
through this loop, it
creates a lock stitch
by intertwining the top thread
with the lower bobbin thread.
The shuttles movement is synchronized
with the needles up-and-down motion.
The shuttle was pushed around by pieces
of metal tightly enough
that it didn't fall out,
but with enough of a gap for the thread
to pass all the way around the shuttle.
This type of sewing machine
was incredibly common
in the late 1800s.
Many millions of just the
Singer Model 27 were made,
and they were built incredibly robustly.
There are many machines that are now
over a hundred years old
that are still working.
Sewing machines were
developed before the idea
of planned obsolescence took off.
The second patent that Wilson
received in 1851 is the basis
for how most modern sewing machines work.
Instead of a shuttle moving
back and forth, the bobbin is
inside a rotating hook.
So let's see how that works.
The needle comes down,
pulling that top thread,
and it goes down really low,
and then it pops back up a little bit
creating this little bulge right here.
And when the rotating hook
comes around, it is grabbed
by that rotating hook,
pulling even more thread
so that this thread can pass
entirely around the bobbin.
And then needle pops back up.
We pull in the excess
and we've formed another
lock stitch like so.
From this, it might look
like you're using more thread
from the top because when
this thread comes in, you need
to pass an entire loop around the bobbin
but that thread then gets pulled back up.
So we actually filmed
in slow motion a sewing
machine using a gradient thread
so you can see just how much
thread is getting pulled
in from the top.
It looks like a lot, but
ultimately you use the same amount
of thread from the top spool
as from the bottom spool.
The tension needs to be identical
on both the top and bottom thread
so the same amount of thread
is used in each stitch.
If the tension is off, the
stitch won't meet perfectly
in the middle of the two fabrics leading
to a much weaker stitch.
This is true for both vibrating shuttle
and rotating hook lock stitch machines.
But what does result is a lot of friction.
You can imagine this piece
of thread is getting pulled back down
and back up a whole bunch
of times with every stitch.
So what was developed
was actually a groove
in the sewing needle right here
to reduce the friction between
the thread and the fabric
as it has to keep getting pulled down
to go around the bobbin
and then get pulled back up
when it's tensioned again.
This resulted in less fraying
of both thread and fabric
and resulted in a cleaner stitch.
Practically all modern sewing
machine needles have a groove
on one side.
But there's still an
important piece missing.
After a stitch has been made,
how do you move the fabric?
(dramatic music)
In the earliest sewing machines,
the fabric would be moved
by hand after every stitch,
but that was obviously slow, inefficient,
and the stitches wouldn't
have been identically spaced.
A few designs were attempted,
but the most successful
one was also invented
by Allen B. Wilson.
His idea was a small
piece of metal, the foot
that would press down on the fabric.
When the needle is not in the
fabric, a small piece of metal
with grooves in it pushes up from below.
It grabs the fabric and
then moves back a fraction
of an inch advancing it to
where the next stitch should be.
This design is used
in practically all sewing machines today.
They're called feed dogs.
There are some modified versions
of this idea, like the
universal feed machine used
for chain stitch embroidery.
- With these style of machines,
there's a handle underneath the machine
and it rotates the entire
nose of the machine.
- [Derek] Okay.
- And this presser foot,
that will basically advance
the fabric in 360 degrees.
So right now we've got this
hooked up to a single motor,
but back then these cables
went up to the ceiling
and were all powered by one big generator,
one big like steam power
or coal powered generator.
And so I'm sure the
factories were so loud.
There used to be a pin,
we've taken them off just
'cause we don't need them anymore.
And what you would do is you'd pull down
and it would immediately
engage the machine
because this was spinning continuously
'cause it was all hooked up by one motor.
Like nowadays, when you
start a machine, you can kind
of like feather it a little
bit, you can start slow.
Back then, they were going
like 10,000 rpm right away.
- [Derek] You got to gotta be ready.
- Yep. Those women were heroes.
I mean, unbelievable skill.
- The most famous name associated
with sewing machines is
that of Isaac Singer.
But Singer did not invent
the sewing machine.
He was a shrewd businessman
buying up patents
for various parts and
building his company on that.
Inspired by interchangeable parts
that he saw in production of firearms,
he optimized the production process
and his company was able to drop the price
of sewing machines from a
hundred dollars to around $10.
That's just over $300 in 2023 terms.
This lower price meant he
could sell the machines
to families rather than to corporations.
Singer's business was also one
of the earliest in the world
to offer an installment payment
plan, allowing the buyer
to pay it off over a few months,
rather than paying the
entire cost upfront.
Singer became one of the largest
corporations in the world
and the first American
multinational company.
Before the advent of sewing
machines, it would take
over 12 hours to sew a single shirt.
It now takes less than 30 minutes.
In 1900, the average American
family spent about 15%
of its total income on clothing.
In 2003, it was less than 4%,
but despite spending
less, we own more clothes.
In 2019, the worldwide average number
of garments owned was over 130.
Each year, a hundred billion
garments are produced.
And just in the US
alone, 11.3 million tons
of clothing ends up in landfill.
That's nearly 35 kilograms of
clothing for every man, woman,
and child that is thrown away each year.
But should we blame sewing machines?
The sewing machine is brilliant.
Invented, iterated upon, and
improved by dozens of people.
They really have revolutionized the world.
All it took was inventing a
completely new way to sew.
Hey, this part of the
video was brought to you
by KiwiCo, a company that's
all about making science
and learning about the
world fun and engaging.
I know that the best way to
learn is through interactivity
and I personally got a
much better understanding
of sewing machines by building models,
actually using a sewing
machine, taking it apart
and putting it back together.
Now, KiwiCo have been a
longtime sponsor of the channel
because they genuinely
make great products.
I mean, my children love them.
Not only are they a great learning tool,
but they're also really fun.
When the crates arrive at my
doorstep, my kids can't wait
to open them and start
putting the projects together.
This month we built a coin eating robot,
and amidst all the fun they were having,
there were also lessons in
electric circuitry, cams
and mechanical linkages.
Each crate comes with all
the the materials you need,
detailed instructions and an explanation
of the science behind the project.
It's so nice that everything is there
and ready to go, so you don't
need to run out to the store
or gather any extra supplies.
I can just enjoy quality time playing
and learning with my kids.
The crates are designed by experts
to be educational and enjoyable,
and they have different
product lines to cater
to all age groups down to newborns.
KiwiCo believes that the best
way to learn is by doing,
and that is definitely a
philosophy I can get behind.
So go to kiwico.com/veritasium
to get your first month's crate free.
This offer is exclusive
to Veritasium viewers,
and with the holiday season coming up,
this is your friendly reminder
that KiwiCo crates also make great gifts.
So go to kiwico.com/veritasium, subscribe
and get your first month's crate for free.
I want to thank KiwiCo
for sponsoring this part
of the video, and I wanna
thank you for watching.